thank you very much
dr melamed and i want to thank the los
angeles museum of the holocaust for
giving me this opportunity to speak
today
to you
am i
can you hear me in the back
i should speak more loudly
is this better
better
or too loud
okay i'm looking at the back of you okay
and i also want to make sure i don't
speak too quickly
i get very
excited about my research and sometimes
i start speaking too quickly so i hope
that you're going to give me a little
signal in the back both in terms of the
the
your ability to hear me and whether or
not i should slow down a little bit
um i'm really happy to be here uh dr
melan
and i actually have done some research
together in the field in ukraine um we
worked on that diary project together
the diary of samuel goldfard
and it was a very very special project
took many years to produce not as long
as this one
but a completely different perspective
on the holocaust from the from the eyes
of one jewish man a polish jewish man
who found himself um in the maelstrom of
of of of the of the mass murder in
galicia so
i just wanted to mention that uh dr
melamed's contribution to that
particular project was really
significant so i want to thank you for
that
okay now this story of women ordinary
german women was not something that i
went to the archives looking for
i went to the archives in the former
soviet union in ukraine in the summer of
1992 with a completely different
question and this is rather typical of
historical research that you think
you're going to go after something and
then you go into an archive and you find
a file that just looks kind of strange
and curious and it gets you you know
wondering why is this here and you you
kind of put it on your desk you know and
then you think maybe this will develop
into something i'm not sure
um so in the summer of 1992
um the soviet union had collapsed
ukraine had just become an independent
country as of august 1991 and for me i
saw that as an opportunity as a scholar
budding scholar i was a graduate student
to go into this territory and to try to
see what was there i had been looking at
material in the national archives in
washington dc the things that the
military had scooped up the allies had
scooped up things like the nuremberg
trial documents and captured german
records
and a lot of that material that was in
washington
was essentially the the high command
orders things that were captured in
germany proper documents from berlin
documents from other kind of nazi
agencies that were headquartered in
germany itself um so the question
remained you know what about all those
regional offices where the germans had
set up their operations in ukraine in
belarus and the baltics lithuania latvia
estonia where these crimes occurred what
about what was going on out there in the
field and it really took the collapse of
the soviet union for us to not only get
access to those materials and to get
into those archives but to start to
really understand and imagine the scope
of the violence that was occurring in
these kind of open air settings outside
those gassing center those those killing
centers like auschwitz sobi bortra
blinka and now if you're familiar with
the work of someone like timothy snyder
bloodlands it's even more apparent to us
now more evident that
it's possible that as close to half the
victims of the holocaust
perished
outside of these gassing centers in the
open air mass shootings in the ghetto
liquidations during the deportations
um you know in these open you know in
these communities okay
so my first trip in the summer of 1992 i
made my way to the jatomer regional
archive about 100 miles
um
about 100
sorry
yeah but 100 miles from kiev i was on my
way to kiev and the reason why i went
there
was because i figured out from my
advisors work richard brightman wrote an
excellent um study of heinrich himmler
the reichsphere of ss the head of the
whole ss and police apparatus
that himmler had his headquarters in
chatomer
and that hitler had his headquarters in
vinitsa about about 50 60 miles due
south and so i thought well here's an
interesting place
it's in the heart of the pale settlement
which was historically very important
for jewish
russian jewish history catherine the
great set up this reservation confined
the jewish population of the russian
umpire to this particular area so it was
kind of the heartland of jewish history
in the czarist empire obviously a large
population of jews these communities had
concentrations of jews sometimes thirty
to fifty percent in towns like
beredichev novgorod
of course around kiev
and i thought okay you've got you know
hitler and himmler stationed there a
high concentration of jews
maybe there's german documentation from
the war in these regional archives and i
can start to understand what happened
locally and whether or not hitler and
himmler had a direct influence on that
and in the early 90s the big question
holocaust historiography
was the decision-making question when
did the holocaust begin what can we find
a smoking gun a hitler order and that
was really what i was thinking when i
went out there i was naive enough to
think well maybe i'm gonna find you know
because often some of the most important
material does not turn up you know in
the headquarters but because someone
gets copied on a file at a lower level
and it ends up in in one of these local
regional archives so i thought maybe i'm
going to find you know some really
important high-level direct
directives that are going to tell us
more about
how the holocaust started and the direct
you know that hitler and himmler's
direct um uh
influence on that
when i got to the archives um i was
astounded because there was a
significant collection of material
things that i knew no one had looked at
before i mean these these were files
that
had literally you know footprints on the
on the documents the edges were burned i
could just imagine when the red army
came in at the end of 1943 to this
region and reoccupied it that they were
just
picking this stuff up the street because
there was warfare in the city and
shoving these things in files um and the
archivists there was incredibly
gracious because of this this moment in
time this kind of
ukraine was just
establishing itself as a country that
hadn't really instituted archival
procedures in a way there was a lot of
open access things that had been
classified they were giving to me
they've been bringing me tea and
sandwiches and doing very very nice
things that i didn't expect
um but
the woman who was very generous with the
material she didn't read german and i
was looking at german files and so that
was interesting i thought well she
doesn't really know what's in here and i
i found a lot of material and there's no
copy machine so i was just transcribing
as fast as i could
and among the files was uh was this list
a very innocuous kind of personnel list
that showed young
freud line of young women unmarried
women
and i could see from their birth dates
that they were basically between the
ages of like 18 and 25
and they were sent to that region as um
kindergarten teachers and welfare
workers and they were sent charged with
doing the kind of
colonial missionary work they were
supposed to be kind of civilizing you
know the ethnic germans germanizing this
region because this is going to be
the in nazi thinking the utopia the the
laban's round the living space it's
going to be the empire for germans only
hitler had referred to
parts of ukraine around on the crimea he
said this is going to be our riviera
um they were building an autobahn
through there it was going to be you
know
in their mind it was a tabula rasa
non-germans were going to be eliminated
starting with the jews and they were
also going to completely transform this
landscape down to every flower and bush
i mean they had botanists there they had
all these technocrats and specialists
going around trying to turn this into
the utopia and that's why hitler hitler
and himmler were located in this
particular region because they had a
direct hand and especially himmler in
creating these experimental colonies and
so these women were brought in
to participate in that in this in this
colonization process and i didn't i was
i thought at that point i figured this
out through my research later on but
initially i thought why are these young
women here
this is a war zone this is you know
where the uh war of destruction as the
germans called it is taking place as
titanic struggle the partisan warfare
the military campaigns obviously i
thought that ordinary german women were
at home
taking care of the home front and having
babies for the fewer so that more
soldiers could go into battle and more
territory could be conquered
here is
an example of the kind of document this
is not from the jatomar archive but
just to show you
um this personnel list this is from riga
so now i started to realize that this
phenomenon of these women going east
could be i could start to pick find
documentation from other parts
of eastern europe local regional records
and these are young women you can see
freudline has
falberger
they're telephone operators one is
situated in the fort zimmer and riga the
kind of uh you know office
foyer
as an
kind of an executive secretary um in
that front office and starting to figure
out um through this documentation that
women um that this chatomer
document that i found is possibly
um the tip of the iceberg and when i
went back to uh washington after that
first trip i went back to ukraine then
several times after that
um
i looked at what existed that okay
if i've discovered some let me see if
general holocaust history court or
general holocaust history books and kind
of nazi germany books and
books on the second world war to what
extent do women figure in these books
are they present in these places maybe
maybe someone else has already come
across this
and documented and talked about it
and i started to look at some of the
standard um when i couldn't find the uh
find the women in the indices of the
books that i was looking at of course i
would find some women as campguards but
i was really trying to find them on the
map of eastern europe and the so-called
laban's room
i was not finding them i was finding
them a lot of photographs you know i
just had to expand my research
effort into all different types of
sources this is the challenge of writing
women's history and especially of
writing writing about women who are
emerging in these places in all
different capacities you know if a wife
or a girlfriend goes out to the eastern
territories
she is not going to be there's not going
to be a big paper trail but you find
these these women
circulating and we find them in
photographs and this is classic
uh image
of a group shot here we have a group
from treblinka
um
the commandant some of the some of the
personnel there and you see the woman
seated next to the man with her arm
wrapped around him i think
august henst who was a cook in triplink
and then it says on the caption an
unknown an unknown woman and then
there's another unknown woman down there
below and on the cover of this book
there's another unknown woman
and i wanted to find out who these
unknown women were and just how many of
them were there and what were they doing
um in holocaust historiography i also
noticed that a lot of research had been
devoted to coming up with
different perpetrator types
so we had these kind of
characterizations that emerged in the
literature you have
of course the sadistic killer
you have the eliminationist anti-semite
you have the ordinary man you have the
banal bureaucrat the eichmann the
technocrat
um the foot soldier
so
these types had emerged and there we
were expanding our understanding of
perpetration of the holocaust with these
kinds of nuances and this similar kind
of development was not happening
vis-a-vis how we understood women's role
um
so that was something i i thought about
and i thought well
is there a female version of an eichmann
is there a female version of an ordinary
uh man um is there a female version
where women put in uniform were they put
into kind of killing units or all the
things that i had read about male
perpetrators i started to question to
what extent women might fit into those
categories
then i went back to the standard
documentation that we'd been using so
that was the my review of the literature
then i went back in to the archives to
some of the things that we've been using
in investigative material even the
nuremberg material
and i started to notice that women
were called to testify a lot they were
brought in um they were very
instrumental for instance at the at the
nuremberg trials i started to realize
well
these women they're bring coming in to
testify against their male bosses or
even their spouses
they have a lot of information they are
providing a lot of historical valuable
information to prosecutors information
that historians have called have pulled
out of these documentations and written
history from
but not really question why does this
woman know so much
how come she's telling me every detail
about the procedures that were taken
in the proper way that documents were
handled how orders were conveyed to
killing units
the mood in the office
what happened you know in terms of the
distribution of property who had access
to the to the safe you know to
classified material
uh i've identifying obviously killers
and often even describing scenes at
actual massacres at these killing sites
and so i started to realize as well that
the
that women's testimony had been kind of
underappreciated
or taken for granted in many ways and
that we hadn't asked in looking at that
testimony how come they know so much
they must have been there and if they
were there well what did they do uh that
they're not revealing in this testimony
we have to we have to go back to these
traditional sources and ask
new questions
and eventually
i was able to determine by
this collecting effort that went on
many years
that there were approximately and this
is a kind of a rough estimate and future
research may in fact change this
but
i could account for about a half a
million
german women who circulated in the
eastern territories
during the war in different capacities
um the german red cross trained 640 000
women during the nazi era 400 000 of the
of them were in wartime service and some
300 000 of them were in the eastern
territories the german army trained
another half a million women in support
positions as flight recorders radio
operators wiretappers
hitler or excuse me himmler's
reich's the rights for ss he trained
some 30 000 women and certified them and
they had to actually sign an oath to the
ss of to to maintain secrecy for
instance and these were special
auxiliaries in john d'arm offices
gestapo headquarters
um and prisons
2500 2 500 teachers were sent to one
region alone in poland to participate in
this germanization effort to uh to uh
set up kindergartens um when the german
refugees came in to kind of teach them
all about the nazi ideology and so forth
um
so this were these were 200 and of
course over 200 000 women 240 000 women
were ss brides you know had applied to
be the wives of s-men ss men and they
were encouraged to go
stay with their men because the ss
organization was also a kind of breeding
organization elite racial organization
so
um they're they we find many ss wives in
these locations where their men were so
that they could um be together and and
uh
propagate you know continue to uh to to
um promote the race and and have have
more children um here's an image i think
it's it's quite uh
uh illustrative of this phenomenon the
nurses being sworn in in berlin and you
can just see the magnitude of this this
is during the war all the all of them in
uniform and then that other image to the
right is from the cover of a brochure
um the east needs you and this is trying
to recruit women to be
resettlement advisors so that when
ethnic german refugees were brought into
these colonies it was german women the
german women who were brought in to
teach them uh the language teach them
german songs german cooking how to
maintain a proper german household all
of these kinds of activities
now
while i was putting this picture
together of
what it came to be what i came to
realize was a whole generation
of german women because if you think
about it
who are the individuals who are going to
be going off
you know in the nursing staffs in the
secretarial staffs as the wives these
are young women right young women who
are fertile who can
reproduce the right reproduce for hitler
and also young women who are
single who are working in these offices
and working in the nursing professions
and as teachers so suddenly i noticed
that most of these women were born
between
19
20 and 19 24 thereabouts and so now i
not only had women on the eastern
territories but i had a kind of
it looked like a kind of generational
phenomenon that was emerging so i
started to refer to them as these first
world war one baby boomers
um and this fits into the general uh
uh history of of nazi germany that
the leadership itself was young
those who committed these crimes were
young
within the german population
you had people like hitler and himmler
you know uh in their 40s with enormous
amounts of power and
similarly women you know of marriage age
in their 20s also wielding
considerable power and the implications
of that of
young people wielding this kind of power
life and death
ability to make life-and-death decisions
over non-germans
in the summer of 2005
i was at the u.s holocaust memorial
museum
still on this kind of collecting effort
piecing this together
i hadn't written up my results yet i was
just
things were just starting to take shape
and i
at this point wasn't really sure
how close the women got to the actual
killing and i i could i could i could i
had evidence to show that they were many
more were direct witnesses that many
more were in the machinery as
secretaries um in particular
um but i didn't have a lot of cases of
of killers and and in the last couple of
years this is when i started to
to turn these up as my research focused
on those uh perpetrators and this is a
case uh that i came across in the
archives in washington and i
uh distinctly remember going through
that microfilm and
being really just so uh
astonished by this
these documents even 60 plus years after
the events
was absolutely
chilling
this case is one of the more prominent
ones in my book the name of the
individual is erna petri
and the reason why we have this
documentation on this
killer
is because she was arrested by the east
germans
and she was
interrogated by the stasi the east
german police
and this report she was
her husband the two of them
stood trial together in 1962.
so i mean when i looked in the finding
and i thought this is an unbelievable
case a husband and wife
standing trial together
the husband gets the guillotine she gets
a life sentence and they've committed
their crimes
on a farm in ukraine outside the camp
system so already when i saw it on the
finding it i thought this i gotta look
at this case
and then i get into the reel and i see
this confession here you can see on the
right that's her arrest
um certificate
when she's apprehended that's her mug
shot and there to the right is the
beginning of what is a confession and if
you look up on the right hand corner
um if you can make that out you can see
that she's interrogated
the full day with i think one lunch
break and it starts in the morning and
it ends at 9 45 and of course this is a
nice clean copy
someone you know got the information out
of her and then they made this
this digest of it for for the record
and this in this document she admits to
killing six jewish boys
on their farm um and shooting them
in the back of the of the neck
um
so erna petru is one of an entire
generation of young german women who saw
their future
in the reich in the eastern territories
and they arrived there through all
different paths and trajectories but
they shared certain outlooks certain
ambitions erna petri admitted in her
confession that the reason why she
killed those children was because she
had been so indoctrinated in the 1920s
and taught to hate jews she also said in
her confession that she wanted to prove
herself
to the men
many of these women
then when they went east were put in all
kinds of confronted all kinds of new
situations but they went there with a
certain idealism certain convictions
certain ambitions and certain hopes and
dreams many of them of course didn't go
voluntarily because they had compulsory
wartime service
but they did share this kind of
nationalist um uh uh
outlook as to you know why they were
there and why they had to defend their
reich even even one of my cases annette
is shooking homer the nurse who was
probably had the most moral
sensibilities and was the most
conflicted about the violence she
confronted she still when i interviewed
her in 2010 it was still clear to me
that you know she didn't question that
she had to be there to defend her
homeland and even after she had seen
some of the most horrific or had heard
about and and
talked to some of the most worst
perpetrators in ukraine she
followed her
her her orders and went to krasnodar
went even deeper farther east into the
into the war zones and that she did not
question um because her sense of duty um
uh prevailed over a kind of uh sense of
morality and in this regard
men were no different um from women so
here you can see the scale both i've
talked about the scale in terms of the
number of women but now you can see
geographically what we're talking about
in terms of the eastern territories um
the
the stretch all the way through poland
um
the baltics up to the north
ukraine belarus and this is where where
these women are
stationed
and this is of course where the most of
the the most of the violence and mass
killing of the holocaust occurred
today i want to in the time remaining
focused just on a couple more case
studies i've mentioned earn a petri
that's one of one of the worst but i
want to stress today that my intention
in writing this book is not
you know
to shock to to just create it is
shocking information it's very
disturbing information when you get to
the cases of of the killers in
particular and just the everyday
experiences of women as they intersected
with the holocaust but i really want
readers to gain a better sense to try to
understand
why the women went there to begin with
what they saw and why they responded in
the different ways that they did the
majority of them were witnesses
then
the next level of participation was kind
of accomplices in the machinery in these
professional capacities and then you had
these outstanding cases of the
perpetrators
anetta shooking homeir is the nurse i
referred to
and she was the one who went to novgorod
velensk uh and then from there she went
to krasnodar
and she's a wonder a very uh
complex character um and i think in many
ways a very likable figure in the book
here's someone who really got thrown
into a situation and was just trying to
find ways to cope with that she was
better educated most of the women in the
book
had grammar school educations and were
members of the
um
german the hitler youth for girls um and
had some sort of secretarial training
um worked as nannies or worked um
helping out on farms um or in you know
restaurants you know kind of kind of
working class annetta on the other hand
had training in law and she actually got
her law degree
in the 1930s which was pretty unusual
um you can see she was born in 1920
she's still alive um and she decided
when she was called upon when the war
broke out and she had to do her
patriotic fulfill her patriotic duty
that she was going to join the red cross
which had a very you know during the
first world war and had developed into a
kind of
organization that attracted middle to
upper class women it was more kind of
distinguished way to show your
patriotism and so she said i'm going to
go to the red cross
and um lo and behold when she she didn't
have medical training she was pulled out
of that training because they
immediately noticed that she was someone
who was very cultured
and they said well you know we're going
to set up these the leadership we're
setting up these special soldiers homes
in the rear areas and the occupied
territories this is a photograph from
her personal album of one of these homes
where the soldiers can find you know
retreats
soldiers going to the front
and then returning can have these
stopovers these places where they can
get german cooking and interact with
nice german women
and relax and recreate and so forth and
so there were about 1200
uh german women like annetta who were
sent to the east to
manage these um uh soldiers homes
and she ended up being sent to uh zvil
uh novgorod villains as i mentioned in
that pop town that had a population
of about 9 000 jews
now shortly before she went on her uh
journey east and for all of these women
this this moment of going east
you know it was transformative they
hadn't been out of their towns most of
them in their villages so this was you
know just to go to a new place was was
enormous change let alone to go to a new
place and suddenly see that they were in
the
in this in these so-called killing in
these killing fields in this the warfare
and the genocide
even before she got there a journalist
in berlin said to her annetta why are
you this is the summer of 1941. why are
you going to the east don't you know
they're killing killing jews there
um so that information had already
circulated back to berlin at least
within this the you know uh the
circles of journalists
and she thought oh you know
really i i can't believe that well i
have to go i've got to follow my orders
i'm going to go anyway then the next
within a few weeks after that she's on
the train and the train stops in brest
in belarus and she's with her friend
lily another nurse and they're sitting
there and these two
german men in uniform get on the come in
and come into her compartment
and they start talking to them and
saying uh talk telling a horrible story
about how he the one confessed he said i
just killed this jewish woman and it was
and it described how it was a how this
um
kind of conflict emerged at the at the
shooting site because this woman had a
disabled um sister and they weren't sure
she was trying to save her sister and um
uh
in any event they ended up killing both
of these jewish women but the men start
to tell her that story and and she
thought oh and then she gets off the
train in her um at her
location where she's been
where she's going to be stationed
and the first night they're having
dinner
and
it's part of orientation and the men at
the table the german officers start to
explain to her that they had shot the
jews recently shot the jews in novgorod
velensk and then she's going for a tour
in town they're showing her around and
they point out one of a man in a
technical battalion unit
points out here's the here's this luch
river there's the river this is where uh
450
jewish men women and children were shot
a few months ago
and this continues she starts to
learn more and more about this because
as she said she told me oftentimes
um
conversations with soldiers got personal
real fast they hadn't been around
these were men who hadn't been around
german women for a long time and they
wanted to talk about this so women
become kind of the recipients of these
kinds of
stories
she becomes so
upset annetta that she writes back
by these stories she writes back to her
mother in november 1941 and she said
these letters and shared them with me
and she wrote to her mother
what papa says is true
people with no moral inhibitions exude a
strange odor
i can now pick out these people
and many of them
really do smell like blood
oh what an enormous slaughterhouse the
world is
one more example of a secretary
a very interesting case
we don't really have a lot of
information on belarus very important
geographically in terms of the holocaust
and very hard area to research
and this case of the secretary in lida
which is near minsk
um
actually was uh brought to my attention
by a colleague of mine uh dr weitman
bjorn and then i did a little bit more
digging eventually had the opportunity
to uh interview this this this man here
this well it was a this isn't during the
war he was a young he was a boy now he's
a grown man that this little guy here to
the to the left
his father the gentleman on the right
was the gabitz commissar the regional
governor
of lita where there was a very
significant population of jews it's not
too far
from um
vilnius
many jews who fled from vilnius
including those who ended up in the
bielski partisans often found refuge in
leta because there was a big a lot of
workshops that have been established
there and commissar hanve was overseeing
all this workshop activity these were
his jews his jewish laborers
um and the entire family moved out to to
lita
in 1942 in the spring of 42 when there
was still a sizable population in the
region and so this young man and his
sisters and his mother were witnesses
went into the workshops and were
actually witnesses to some of these
mass crimes and mass murders
commissioner honvaik was arrested by the
soviets after the war and uh didn't
return and
was was presumably killed after a quick
quick trial
commissioner hanve had a secretary her
name was lisa lota meyer
and um
they became lovers liz letta and
commissar honvaig here we have a picture
of lisalotta i don't know the other
gentleman in the picture these are
photos from personal albums that were
collected during a post-war
investigation of the crimes
in leta and this other photo was among
that
those that were collected this is
someone she's identified as frau
apfelbaum i just think that's an
interesting picture because she's
standing there in the woods with her
shotgun and in fact that's part of
part of the
a lot to meyer
was
according to survivors who testified
after the war one of the most
better informed than many of the
officials
in the station she was seen
on various occasions recreating kind of
carousing
with the german officials with her lover
commissar honvaik
um
in town obviously they had a villa
they were constructing a swimming pool
they had their own personal kind of
jewish laborers who could from the
workshops who could fulfill their every
whim be it jewelry or furs or bring um
all kinds of crafts in fact uh commissar
honvaik uh he commissioned or he
demanded from the jewish laborers
jewelry for his family
they made a train set an electric train
set for his son and presented to him at
christmas when i met with eberhard i was
hoping that maybe he still had some of
these objects
because most of that population was
killed and i i
thought maybe this is something that we
have left from a population that was
incredibly gifted in terms of their
skills as craftsmen as jewelers as
electricians and so forth um he didn't
have the train set but he did have
a ring and that ring is now
on display at the u.s holocaust memorial
museum or it's in their collections for
the time being because they have a very
important exhibit right now at the
museum um on on these kinds of uh this
this history
complicity
now lisa little meyer
was seen going out on different um
record excursions with the locals on the
weekends they would go out on sundays
they had sundays off
and in one particular incident that
survivors described after the war
she and kama saw honvaik and the other
officials and other secretaries went on
their sleds they often went in the snow
into the forest into the and they would
go on hunts they wanted to hunt for
rabbits on this particular occasion they
didn't find rabbits and they did come
across jewish laborers who were uh
shoveling along the the road and they
the german officials with these women um
they told the laborers to just run
across the field
in the snow which obviously is difficult
to to run quickly when you're running in
the snow
and then they shot the the jewish
laborers
be
like they were shooting
um
rabbits
and actually some of those
several jews died right then and there
they were shot killed some of them
actually made it to the forest
they made it to the forest and they
survived and they actually came back and
testified against these individuals
including liz lota meyer and i just
think that's quite something that at
that particular moment when that
incident occurred they probably never
would have imagined
um that any of these uh jewish laborers
would have survived and that
some decades later they would
confront them
be faced with their their testimony
lisaletto meyer did not take kind of
simple dictation from the commissar
she was often told to write up orders
she was also it was told at one point uh
by a testimony was given excuse me that
she authorized the shooting of 16 jews
who appeared late for work
um she was she was very important in
terms of distributing the orders to the
um shooters from the local jean don
marie she she met with the head of the
jewish affairs um uh who came in from
the workshop uh she was just like kind
of at the center of this because of her
relationship with hanvik and because she
had this administrative role
she was able to issue the so-called gold
cards which were life-saving documents
for jewish person other than flight and
suicide the only other way to escape the
shooting pits was to secure a labor
assignment secretaries also were
involved in selections when jewish
victims were marched through town
they could you know literally pull
individuals out of that lineup frau
reichmann from sloanum another secretary
pulled a woman out of the march
deportation march she said she didn't
she had not finished
knitting a sweater for her so she pulled
her out and these kinds of um kind of
spontaneous
acts of what seem to be rescue but
they're often motivated obviously by
greed and personal self-interest
here's a an image i pulled out found in
the archives in germany rather recently
i was couldn't couldn't believe this uh
these are very rare images from
uh lita belarus um here someone took a a
entire series of pictures from the march
1942
um these these are jews who are being
marched into center of town they're
going to be stripped of all their
valuables and then
brought to another location
and shot and you can see the woman on
the right see the silhouette of the
woman on the right and it reminded me of
this what i had read in the testimony of
um
of the role of women
at the at this at these events and here
this particular image
also very
uh
interesting and disturbing
there's commissar hanve with his gun
i don't know who this woman is i've
tried to
match her up with the images of meyer
and of honda's wife
it's it's not clear to me you have a
police official to to her right and then
this if you can make out there's a young
jewish
there's a boy there's a young jewish man
coming out from a kind of hiding place
um and being led
in this direction of course someone is
taking the picture so he's essentially
surrounded and when i spoke to
honvaik's son um
and looked in the testimony one
particular incident in leta kept coming
up in the testimony as a memorable event
and i wonder if this is actually in some
way a depiction of that the event was
that a young jewish man who had been
working in the stalls taking after
looking after the horses
had done something he's stolen something
food or done something very minor
but for that he he had to pay with his
his life he was trying to escape run
away and they caught him and they wanted
to make a
spectacle of this
to warn the other jews not to do this
and they pulled him out and they
hung him up on a a rod and he was left
there and eberhard the child has this
memory of
um seeing that one of the officials
actually had a
german shepherd that he that he
um
the german shepherd was also part of
that scene
attacking the young jewish
jewish man
i don't have time unfortunately to go
through all these cases johanna aldfater
the secretary another secretary
in ukraine actually who
was
seen
doing more than
being involved kind of administratively
but at the actual shooting sites and she
herself was notorious for killing jewish
children
in the ghetto
and even
multiple testimony from dozens of
survivors from america
israel
canada who stated that she had this
nasty habit uh joanna alvarez of
of um
killing these jewish children by
sticking her pistol she had her own
pistol
she fashioned herself like a kind of
cowgirl in the wild east and she would
use that pistol
and place that pistol in them in the ma
in the mouths of the of the children
back in them to her and kill them shoot
them in the mouth
so these were some of the really
disturbing and horrible cases that
that started to emerge as i started to
dig a little bit
deeper
but as i as i stated these are very um
unusual cases but they have to be taken
seriously
not as anomalies i don't see these women
as
kind of freaks of nature or marginal
kind of sociopaths i really came towards
you know as i as i started writing the
book and started to see
the momentum of this regime and the way
that these women were socialized and
what they were even doing many of these
women were also committing these crimes
with their children by their sides what
just how is brutalizing children the
youth the german youth
and so i see this kind of
um you know even looking into the future
that this was headed towards this kind
of
um uh
violence that was socially acceptable
within these
communities people like erna petrie
people like johanna aldfater they were
not punished obviously during the nazi
era for the crimes that they committed
they slipped back into society
in their roles as housewives or
secretaries or youth workers and so
forth they weren't habitual killers
um they just changed their behavior
when the system collapsed that supported
that behavior um they themselves also
went back to what we think was normal
law-abiding citizens and that's why many
of them were not viewed by prosecutors
as uh as culpable were not taken
seriously
men and women are capable of voracious
greed because greed is another part of
the story women are at the center of
this consumption this culture of
consumption that's driving the holocaust
not because of their gender but in spite
of it
acting as human beings in extreme
circumstances who have become convinced
of an idea and of their own power to
realize this idea
assuming that women are not capable of
extreme violence and the kind of
political engagement and activism that
was behind that in this history
is a socio-cultural bias that has
positive and negative connotations
on the one hand this gender construction
is a sign of hope that at least half the
human race will not devour the other and
in protecting the children will
safeguard the future
on the other hand minimizing the violent
behavior of women creates a false
shield blocks us from the more direct
confrontation with genocide and all of
the discomforting realities of it
the consensus in holocaust and genocide
studies is that the systems that make
mass murder possible would not function
without the broad participation of
society and yet nearly all histories of
the holocaust leave out half of those
who populated that society as if women's
history happens somewhere else
it is an illogical approach and puzzling
a mission
the shocking stories of hitler's furies
reveal the darkest side of female
activism
they show what can happen when women are
mobilized for war and acquiesce and
genocide thank you very much
[Music]
[Applause]
great lecture and especially you can
draw
your conclusion from this conclusion
about globalization in the genocide
about ordinary government ordinary
german and now
first of all we'll take a question maybe
we'll limit not muslim bangling it to
give
more people
i mean ability to ask questions
sure sir
yes you mentioned that some of at least
one coach here of these women would
speak with german soldiers who had
uh to confess in a sense to them
now use the term soldier rather than ss
and i'm wondering
therefore was it well known in the
germans right almost at the beginning of
the war as these soldiers would confess
that it was well known in germany that
jews were being slaughtered in east
because what we've heard is the excuse
we didn't know right right
well we know that the regular german
army is was much more involved regular
german military units than was admitted
to after the war so the clean myth of
the vermont as was called has now been
completely debunked and that came out um
uh
well yeah he was in the regular military
that's true he was in yugoslavia but now
um the the the main story that came out
um after this exhibit this controversial
exhibit was circulating in germany was
just a regular kind of like the sixth
army for instance the sixth army was the
the army that went to stalingrad and
there was the kind of martyred army
because of the big defeat and so forth
well it turns out that the sixth army on
its march to stalingrad
you know was one of the most you know
had a bloody trail behind it of of
involvement in mass shootings against
jews
um so these guys so
when the army came in in 41 soviet union
um with these
ss motorized killing units the ions
that's grouping and they they station
themselves in places like chatomer or
berdychev or community poduls and they
had to and bobby yar right kiev and they
plan these massive operations of you
know shooting operations
thousands of of victims
those uh einstein's group and they they
might be the primary uh kind of shooting
form the actual execution squad um but
this kind of
mass murder was
it lasted for hours and it required a
lot of personnel
and and there was change over in terms
of who was doing the shooting so you had
regular soldiers coming in as relief
shooters you know cordoning off the
areas taking a lot of photographs that
were circulating talk about knowledge
the ss himmler had to keep issuing
orders around the eastern front stop
taking pictures you know a lot of these
soldiers were told you know you're
making history and in the regular
vermont um
uh magazines the uh german equivalent of
like a kodak like agfa they're
advertising get your personal
you know your camera your snapchat
camera and bring it with you and
document this wonderful history you're
participating in well they're also also
documenting the the killing because
that's part of what they what this uh
campaign was all about um so you have a
lot of evidence from soldiers in terms
of the documentation and these are
circulating these images
some of these images are being developed
back in germany i spoke to a woman
in near dachau
in bavaria was one of my witnesses and
her job she was a young woman like these
young women she was a photo labor labor
technician
um and she's sitting in munich
developing photos of these atrocities on
the eastern front
um
so that's a basically the myth
was the warm-up was somehow separate
no it's it was all intertwined so that
the myth also that the ordinary german
didn't know what they attracted these
words
yeah we know from diaries like um
the diary of um the dresden klemper you
know we're starting to find entries and
diaries even in the fall of 41 he
mentions bobby r
uh so the information is circulating
unlike the allied armies for instance
the german army they're moving back and
forth from the front to the home
so they can't really the communications
aren't cut off in that regard even if
they have sensors monitoring the mail
you know people are actually moving back
and forth um so yeah the knowledge was
definitely definitely circulating yeah
i listened to your book yesterday in
audible
that's why it's great seeing all these
things spelled out because i couldn't
figure out how to pronounce it yeah
but i want to say first of all it's
amazing that you were able so many years
after this all happened in our recent
times to have a book on a subject nobody
else has ever written but this is my one
question you use the expression slipped
into society
and after listening to the book
obviously there are so many women that
were involved and never nobody ever
happened to them and you said many of
them slipped into society after you met
some of these people can anybody ever
get like prosecuted for what they did
because of all the work you said you've
been doing this project for 20 years did
you ever find somebody who because of
what they did you reported them or
something and they got in trouble and
they went to prison and make something
happen that's what i didn't quite get
okay so most of the women
slip back into society post-war is what
you mean right kind of
were able to remain
um
inconspicuous
including some of the worst perpetrators
but of course the perpetrators i have
the few that i have in the book are be
you know i know about them because of
for instance that document i showed you
that the stasi had arrested her and she
got a life sentence
and johanna aldfader was was arrested by
the west germans the secretary who was
killing the children but she was
acquitted twice
in 79 and 82 despite all the evidence um
uh well the overall a couple reasons the
um
first of all uh they didn't take the
prosecutor or interview the prosecutor
because i was curious i had the same
question um and as he explained it to me
he believed that she was guilty he
believed she did what she did but he
couldn't in a court the courtroom
actually get a conviction because it was
based on survivor testimony which was
not taken as seriously as you know the
hard evidence documentation
so this is where it's tricky because you
know with the male perpetrators you can
reconstruct particular units at
particular that were assigned to
particular killing actions and put a man
in one of those units like order police
battalion 101 with many of these female
perpetrators outside the camp system if
you can't get them on a campguard list
um you know if you got them if they're
on a regular personnel list as a
secretary so these women who are
committing these crimes they're not
following orders
when they're doing making this they're
they're they are doing this on their own
they're making that choice
and that's
all the more the the fact that they're
not prosecuted is all the more
astounding because in west germany for
instance the statue of limitations ran
out in the 60s against um everything but
the crime of murder right so these
accomplices in the machinery the
secretaries they can't be pursued
right even someone like eichmann i
started to wonder you know if he'd been
brought to germany instead of to israel
he might not have been convicted
because he could have been you know if
they couldn't place him at the crime
scene with blood on his hands so after a
certain point
the west germans in this case they've
got to prove base motive they've got to
prove that these
killers are have anti-semitic
convictions are sadistic you know are
really excessive in their in their
behavior
and so the the paradox here is that we
have women
survivors saying look at what these
women were doing
i've described some of this to you
multiple survivors from different
countries they're not talking to each
other they've gone emigrated to
different places this is the 60s they're
not emailing each other you know and so
they come into a courtroom and they have
this corroborating testimony testimony
that shows that these women are doing
things that are
that clear base motive and they're still
not convicted
um
so
i just have a question my emotions are
very good
um
i perhaps i didn't understand very well
why did you separate these women that
collaborated in
belarus and
ukraine
from the women that collaborated in the
indicate in the
concentration camps
yeah because the couples
they were the campers there
a lot of women
some were jews too
but some
the most of the women were
german
so why did you
why did you take this
this group
separate from that
yeah
well um the literature had established
that about 3500 women served as guards
we have documentation for that from
robbinsbrook most of them have been
trained there
and so the the literature in the
holocaust in terms of female
perpetrators really focused on these
guards
and and i my book is arguing that the
participation is much bigger than that
and we can't think of the holocaust as
confined to these
spaces entirely these closed
um uh camp settings although they're
very important they're really central to
the story but they're not the entire
story
um it it's a much broader uh uh
level of participation
and in all these different forms we
can't just think of
it as a guard per se in the same way
that we develop these storiography or
the interpretations of men but all these
different functions that that make
genocide possible
men and women together working in these
different roles and in these different
settings outside of the camp system in
their homes you know in their villas
on their picnics in these remote
regional outposts
um
at train platforms i mean not in these
institutional
and institutionally closed settings once
you you once those walls come down of
those settings and they and they are
down now i mean the storeography we have
now shows that camps like dachau and
auschwitz birkenau were not so closed
off from society there there's a lot of
penetration of the outdoor outside and
inside i interviewed people who were
delivering
you know refreshment they were bringing
uh
the bottles you know juice and water
making these deliveries into dachau and
there's just the community is very you
know the very poorest these these sites
we know from
uh
the holocaust museum's incredible
research that you know we've got man is
more than 40 000 camps the whole camp
universe now has is we have to
understand is much larger right that
means we also have more guards i can't
believe we can talk about now 40 000
camps and not raise the the number of
female guards
and keep that at 3 500
so that story will change
um
but i wanted to show that this was
something you know
much much more widespread and and varied
in its in its forms
when you showed the yeah
i found that very interesting because it
appears that you said most a lot of us
took place in eastern uh territory
eastern nazi territory which appears to
be
ussr
you got
okay this this shaded area moving all
the way to stalingrad is a good part of
that is the military occupied towns okay
um but the so-called commissary it's
like comes from han bay that's the
language the ministry of language
announces you so the right commissary
applause line which is basically the
baltics in belarus and then right here
ukraine
those were which is this sloth kind of
this bigger section here
um
so russia like western russia
moscow obviously leningrad stalingrad
that's part of the military occupation
zone but women were there too as nurses
primarily
and these soldiers homes were set up
kind of right in that rear area but this
is you know this this is the geographic
um the other question i had was
i mean it's just obviously very wide
spread
the other question
was when you mentioned
where did you
absolutely um
this women were really
this is one of their main
activities as featured in the book i
mean i've got spouses of of ss and
regular order police and secretaries and
they are
amassing
a huge huge amount of plunder um either
because they get access to
the depots near the killing center so
near like sobibor in treblinka or just
from the actual mass killing sites and i
mean the nurse that i highlighted today
at one point she described to me how she
was charged with going through the
clothing that had been
you know taken from the killing site and
was being mended and repaired and sent
back to germany through the
welfare association which was very much
a women's kind of professional
charitable organization so they're
handling the movement of literally
jewish clothes cleaning them um mending
them and and sending them back to the to
the reich we're saying them to ethnic
german refugees
um and so this is part of it the
secretary sabina dick who was in minsk
that case
uh because so many jews were deported to
minsk um from germany and and and
killed in mali trust and nuts this place
outside the city
um huge uh
barns barnes filled overflowing with
with jewish belongings
um and they developed a whole language
in the office around this which i think
is is so much going on behind the scenes
that these
uh that's part of this history they talk
about you didn't waste like jewish
sausage like they're the women are
organizing the food that's confiscated
uh is coming into the office and it's
part of
uh like when you are in a modern day
office and people are putting food out
or or maybe they didn't have
a celebration and they're taking eating
this food and talking about it
the the gold gold that's taken from the
bodies uh in the safe that sabine has
access to as a secretary
very very important incident
she needed a gold filling she went to
the dentist and she needed a gold
filling and her boss said to her
just come and bring a certificate
and you can have access to the safe and
take the gold that's
in the safe and she was questioned about
that after the war and she insisted that
um she did not have that goal that it
somehow got lost she didn't deny taking
it she said it got lost uh somewhere
during uh at the end of the war
when their house's house was raided
during the red army occupation nobody
nobody the prosecutor didn't tell her to
open her mouth i don't know maybe maybe
she had it in her mouth
a lot of these women who were there in
traditionally do do well do good fields
nursing welfare social work
did you find it realistic but did you
find any stories of people that were
subverting the efforts
otherwise like any schindler's
types in this area i mean because they
initially all of their education one
that were in fact educated we're
advocating fields of service
i mean it's so
conflict with
you know clearly
right what we think of in terms of women
and their being kind of mediators or
nurturing or maybe involved in more
resistance activities kind of
uh maybe even encouraging their husband
not to be so violent playing these kinds
of roles and indeed there were these
cases
um and i there's one case in particular
that's in the book
um frau hazenstein from uh levof lev
um and she was uh
involved in hiding
a jewish girl i believe
and she was the wife i think she was the
wife of the forester
um
and she was brought before a special
court
and she was given the death sentence she
was killed and the judge in the verdict
in that this is a nazi court
at the end of the war said she should
have known better she came from an
educated household and she should have
known better
so these stories of of women who did
defy the system they're also very hard
to piece together
but they are there
and i you know i think that that's
something that also has to be researched
i don't think they're as numerous as the
picture that i just portrayed today but
it's important also to to document them
the young woman
who was the photo uh technician
uh the reason why i know about her is
because she was actually hiding those
photographs and hiding other things from
the dachau camp
um in her family's beehive because the
gestapo wasn't going to stick their hand
in her beehive to find things which is
smart hiding place
and she was identified by the community
of dachau as a right you know as a
for her civil courage
and so she she was also a young german
woman who
for various reasons tried to to do
something
um
uh
in an individual way but but most of
these women annetta shook homer was so
at the end she said what could i have
done the nurse i was talking about
what could i have done it was you know
i'm i was me and in this entire system
what could i have done
do you think a lot of them felt guilty
about what they did or were they happy
if they had to do it over against
it's so hard to
document and even interpret
what might be signs of feelings of shame
or remorse
or embarrassment i mean
when you when you talk to witnesses men
and women
who were involved in this even involved
in the crimes
um
it's
first of all women are not you know
traditionally telling gruesome war
stories so it's difficult for them to to
recount that level of kind of brutality
these or unpleasant
part of the past rather not talk about
that
when it when it is discussed
um you know it's difficult for me to
interpret
psychologically what their
what's what their feelings are about
that
now if someone says to me um and this
has happened in the documentation as
well in person
starts to
speak about jews and use the language of
the time
anti-semitic language of the time as if
time had not passed
then i can conclude that that person
that that ideology is so
embedded in their identity and their
thinking
um
that that is probably how they were
before you know but it's really really
hard
um i think especially with the passage
of time for for people to
express that kind of
um uh
you don't know if it's if it's some
sometimes we mix up shame with remorse
it's very tricky to know what's being
expressed when the person is having a
hard time talking about it
about what what she she witnessed or did
yeah yeah well i think they you know
it's this this we are we have this
ability to adapt
uh human adaptability
um and if you're not on the receiving
end of it i mean if you talk to
if you're not a victim of the crime if
you actually have the power of
committing it
i think um in terms of
trauma and being able to kind of
distance and adapt and move on is
probably a lot easier but i'm
psychologists could tell me
psychoanalysts could probably tell me
otherwise yeah can't answer that's out
of my realm
human
yeah
i mean it isn't unique
and if put in the same situation
do you think we would react
or do you think because we live in the
in the society that we live now
i think the kind of um basic human
behavior that comes out of this history
is
how we it's it's not specifically german
and those those were very special
circumstances at that time that brought
that out
at that moment
in germany in the 20th century and the
jewish population
that's very historically specific but
the kinds of
brutalities the motivations behind it
the greed the way that when men and
women participate in this the systems
that create genocide that is not
uniquely
german
hitler did not invent genocide he
invented auschwitz
yeah
one minute about about how you did the
research you shared with us that you
went into that particular region and got
access in length
to some information and and that's why
you started that wasn't initially what
you were going to do
and then
how many witnesses did you interview and
where else did you find your information
oh
yeah so my research
took me to many archives first of all
i've mentioned the us hmm in dc
holocaust museum archives was in yad
vashem i did went to many archives in
germany
national and regional kind of local
archives
i went back to ukraine several times was
in poland
um
france yahada unum has a collection in
paris
so yeah i went to
various repositories to collect
documentation national archives in
washington
and then did quite a bit of field work
so i was i started an interview project
in germany
um to collect witness testimony and that
often got me closer to people who were
more involved and whenever i found
documentation about some of these women
i sent letters i made phone calls i
tried to find out if they were still
alive
um and if i could talk to them and in
the i ended up picking these 13 women
because
there was the material was rich enough
to tell their stories and also they were
representative of these different types
that identified
but i talked to many other women many
more women and i just couldn't get
enough you know i could get something on
one chapter of their lives but not i
wanted the book to be like 20th century
the entire trajectory to put that
chapter in that context you know from
1920 to the present so i spoke to
i interviewed about 40 witnesses
and the 13 women here i had director in
indirect contact with seven of them
because um several had had passed away
earn a petri died
um in
uh 2000 i believe or 2003. i can't
remember now so many of them had already
passed away
right
in her life
i didn't have a chance to talk to her um
she uh she died in
she died in 2003 um
and erna petrie died in 2000. um
no i didn't i couldn't i could speak to
the i spoke to the prosecutor in that
case i talked i talked to the defense
attorney i talked to jewish uh
witnesses who went to the trial um was
very very interesting but she was
completely demonstrated she conveyed
absolutely no remorse she was actually
um
the way she conducted herself in the
courtroom and the prosecutor said to me
she's someone i would never want to
encounter on a moonlit night she was ice
cold
and in the courtroom
was not a sympathetic defendant
whatsoever
she was indicted for aiding and abetting
in the killing of 9 000 jews
that's another absolutely that's another
issue they're applying the old prussian
criminal code which is regular homicide
regular murder
in a context of genocidal kind of
you know uh system it didn't
didn't fit but you know it can be
interpreted differently today for
instance it's being interpreted
differently it's it's up to the
you know the prosecutor and the judge um
at neta shook homer after the war she
went to the west german investigative
authorities and she sent documentation
about the people she spoke to these
soldiers who admitted that they had
taken part in these mass shootings she
denounced them to the authorities after
the war she was a judge in germany after
the war a very important person figure
in germany and she told me my efforts
were rebuffed there were nazis
everywhere
and i found her fi her the records that
she submitted
in the um
west german investigative file so i
could see what she had sent in and how
they were reacting to it
so
yeah
yeah
you had your hand up here i was curious
two things you mentioned jewish sausage
and i wasn't quite sure what that was
plus i have been part of global's
diaries and he mentioned flesh and jelly
that people resorted to cannibalism in
the part of world war ii so i didn't
know if they ran into that
i mean the cannibalism would probably be
uh references to the soviet pows
um who were left in these camps some
three million soy pows who were killed
during the war because they were
basically either shot or the nazis just
abandoned them in these the vermont the
german military abandoned them in these
pow camps and and they had no rations
and so they resorted to cannibalism
um no the universe is the jewish sausage
is more about
a kind of
office talk
about the plunder you know that was
coming you know in the form of food
yeah
yeah
gosh
[Music]
based on your studies of history
does germany now in fact
accept the reinterpretation that
the people knew what was happening
and that's the way it's being taught so
therefore
it's although it may not be group
responsibility in a sense it is
so i mean if they come to grips with
they have to deal with that enemy
with them as opposed to the previous
explanation
that they were just a
large but a small percentage
i think i think you're getting out to
what extent um germans have come to
terms with this history and today
oh of this broader complicity yeah and
then and i guess the sub-question that
now that the world war two
is
generation
off rapidly
uh if are the new germans accepted
accepting this and dealing with it or is
it now being forgotten it's going to
become
a matter of history
i mean the germans um
west germans in particular over the
years have developed what in aftermath
studies of genocide it's become kind of
a model history like restitution issues
memorialization activities secondary
education so you know it is what what
has happened in germany since the war
is quite uh remarkable and impressive
for a post-genocidal society
right but you've got um the reality of
individuals who participate
in these crimes and this is pretty
specific to west germany also austria
austria is even worse
um so
this is about wanting to return to
normality and to normal understandings
of women females behavior too um that
kind of normality and and
and
you know yes
putting that history behind them and
moving forward and there were steps that
the west germans took that were clearly
um indicative of
not only moving forward but but
but letting people get away with murder
so
the legal reforms that they institute
they let people re-enter this civil
service they let
sabine's dick's boss
who was indicted eventually for killing
11 000 jews he was able to go back into
the police forces after the war that
these people could continue their
careers in these professions that were
already clearly um involved in in the
holocaust so there's that kind of um
story that surely shows that
the system did not really wasn't
aggressive enough and they didn't
interpret the law they could have
interpreted the law differently the
demyania case
you know they suddenly became more
liberal in the interpretation they
couldn't get when damianic was convicted
recently ivan demionic the ukrainian
guard that was a new understanding of
the law they decided um at this late
stage that because he was a guard in
sobibor and sobibor's primary purpose
was to kill it was a murder operation
that one is by association guilty
because you're working in a killing
operation that's
the task right so they suddenly decide
you know this was a broader
interpretation of that that could have
been the case earlier on you know and it
and it wasn't but i think you know the
germans in general they there's
generational issues now um in terms of
confront confrontation with the past
that are you see differences i think
young germans um
those who are in their their teens right
now there's a lot of fatigue
with this subject matter they feel like
they've had too much of it in grammar
school
and ironically they don't get enough of
it in college when i think a university
level is really the time when you
approach the subject seriously
and so there's an effort now that i'm
involved in to try to get holocaust
studies and holocaust professorships and
get it into the curriculum at the
university level
because people need to be trained to to
to run the memorials and to be experts
in this history in germany um so there's
some some pieces you know within the
system they're not perfect um but it's
you know we're still we're still working
on that um it's but it's difficult to
this day
uh uh to there's still some taboos um in
terms of talking about this history and
it's um it's understandable but it's not
insurmountable
excuse me you said you interviewed the
family the children
um yes when i did interview one of the
perpetrators uh the family of uh one of
the perpetrators
it's a really an interesting story and i
don't want to
you've all been so patient so i can't go
into a lot of detail about it um
but they
believed that their mother
was
not
so much of
a perpetrator during the war but a
victim of post-war
injustice
so they really pointed the finger at the
east germans for
arresting the mother
keeping her in jail for her life and
killing their father that was their
experience
because they
you know you cannot blame the children
for the sins of the father i mean they
their experience was the loss of their
parents after the war
what made you get interested
i'm just curious
when did you start getting involved
in the early 90s when i went to graduate
school but i mean i was first kind of
exposed to it in the 80s
i was in vienna in 1985 um studying
german and and music eight 19th century
i hadn't gotten to the 20th century yet
those were the good old days
um
and i it is that point when i was in
vienna kurt waldheim was where that
scandal came out and i was going to some
of these viennese
uh or even smaller towns to these uh
pubs and i was listening to these former
austrian soldiers talk about the eastern
front and
realize that
not yeah oh
oh one last question
of answering another question austria
was even worse right and i
a lack of
investigations and trials there has not
been a
war crimes a trial against a nazi war
criminal
in austria since 1975 excuse me
so
it just you know
and the cases that you read in my book
about the women
in terms of their um
the few that were pursued and the way
they were treated
as defendants was really
with a little bit too much respect
wendy before you lose this happily happy
monday this reminder again or what is
available at the front desk okay thank
you very much thank you thank you
thank you
for such a wonderful question
and
we've got like another lecture
by the congress thank you very much
you're watching book tv non-fiction
authors and books every weekend on
c-span 2.